So let's begin again. May I enter into the eternal divine order of God to place my absolute
nothingness in the heart of the most holy trinity, to give to my God the joy of fulfilling the
purpose of my existence by doing all the acts of my life through the immaculate heart of my mother
Mary and in the divine will of God. And in this same manner may I live, pray, act, eat, walk, sleep,
and do everything. May my soul be devoid of any other longings, wants or desires, and may you my
beloved divine will do with me whatever you want or desire. All I ask is that you bind me to your
most holy will so intimately that I may never swerve from carrying out what I know to be your good
pleasure and that I remain so docile to the movements of your divine will, that you never perceive even
a breath of resistance in my soul to your requests of me. Come divine will with all the angels and saints,
especially my sweet mother Mary, to touch my forehead, to imprint on it the Holy Spirit and
infuse in me true light, so that I may understand the truths and the good that are in these writings
and prayers. Amen. So I want to take up in September the 22nd, 1924. This is an extremely important message.
Louisa said I continue from the last message. While I was writing what I said before,
I saw my sweet Jesus placing his mouth at the place of my heart and feeding me the words that I was
writing. Now you can see very clearly the evidence there that Jesus is the source of the message,
that he feeds heard the words. At the same time I heard a horrible din from afar because Satan
can't actually enter into the divine will. From some who were beating each other and roaring
with such a clamor as to strike fear. And I turning to my Jesus said to him, my Jesus, my love,
who's making such a din? They seem to me like enraged demons.
What do you, what do they want that they rage so much? And Jesus said my daughter really is them.
She knew it was them and at the same time she was asking him because we're always looking for
clarification even when we understand. He said really is them. They would want you not to write
about my will. And when they see you write more important truths on the living in my will,
they suffer a double hell and they torment all the damned even more. Now their rebellion was
against the divine will. Their decision was an eternal decision. They never go back on it.
So when they hear the divine will, it puts them into a terrible stew altogether. When they hear
Jesus revealing how ordinary little creatures like you and me can live in the divine will,
it absolutely enrages them. They are beginning to understand that we are going to take their places
in heaven. They fear so much Jesus said that these writings on my will might come out
because they see themselves losing their kingdom upon earth. Okay, this means that when we operate
in the divine will, that we're pushing back the kingdom of Satan, we need to understand
the importance of what we're actually doing. We're allowing the Lord to establish his kingdom
and we're pushing back the kingdom of Satan. The demons fear so much that these writings on my will
might come out because they see themselves losing their kingdom upon the earth. That means that
anyone who operates in the divine will is pushing back the kingdom of darkness. We need to know the
importance of the mission we're actually involved in. We're enabling the kingdom of God to be established
or we're pushing back the kingdom of darkness. And Jesus says that the demons acquired this
kingdom when human beings, man withdrawing from the divine will, gave free step to his human will.
So we have come across many times that man is his own worst enemy and here it is again that
the more we do it our way and give into the human will, the more opening we give for Satan to actually
have his reign upon the earth. So Satan reigns on the earth when man surrenders his will
to sin to Satan and to the earth. The kingdom of God reigns when man surrenders his will to the
divine will. So this is very clear and very important. Ah yes Jesus said it was precisely then
man withdrawing from the divine will giving into the human will. It was precisely then
that the enemy acquired his kingdom on the earth. If my will could reign upon the earth,
my enemy on his own would shot himself into the deepest of this. Jesus is talking about the
demons making a terrible din because he is revealing the divine will truths to Louisa.
And he says that they fear so much that the divine will truths will come out
because they see themselves losing their kingdom. And the point I made before was that we need to
understand that when we operate in the kingdom of the divine will we're actually pushing back
the kingdom of Satan. And when we give into our own will we're allowing the kingdom of Satan to reign.
That choice is ours. So that's what Jesus explains here. So they fear so much that these
writings on my will might come out because they see themselves losing their kingdom upon the earth
which they acquired when man withdrawing from the divine will gave free step to his human will.
Oh yes it was precisely then that the enemy acquired his kingdom on earth. And if my will could
reign upon the earth that is when the vast majority of us live in the divine will,
my enemy on his own would shot himself into the deepest of this. In other words, Satan wouldn't
be able to stand being upon the earth he'd go to hell by himself. Like that's a rather interesting
thought. So this is why they rage Jesus said with so much fury. They feel the power of my will in
these writings. Now notice what Jesus is saying. The demons actually feel the power in the writings
that we have in this book in front of us. They feel the power when we read it. They feel the power
when we think about it and pray about it and doubly so when we try to put it into practice.
So this is a major spiritual battle that we're actually involved in.
So Jesus said that the demons feel the power of my will in these writings and the mere thought
that they might come out makes them fly into a rage and try anything they can in order to impede
a good that is so great. You however he said to Louisa don't pay attention to them and learn from
this to appreciate my teachings. Now that's much more important for us than it is for Louisa.
Okay so that's Jesus' advice to each one of us to learn to really appreciate what is being revealed
in these teachings. Okay so in the next section he's going to speak about the absolute urgency
of us abandoning ourselves to God. And there's a wonderful revelation here. It's fantastic. So
Louisa said, "My Jesus, I feel that it takes your omnipotent hand for me to write what you say
about living in your will. In the face of so many difficulties that they raise, now they are the
priests, especially when they keep saying to me, 'How is it possible that no other creature has lived
in your divine will?' It must have been incredibly difficult for Louisa being the first person and
having all a lot of negative reaction coming from the priest for what the Lord was revealing to her.
So Louisa said, 'Look, from this negative reaction, she said, 'I feel so annihilated that I'd want
to disappear from the face of the earth so that no one may ever see me again. But against my will,
I am forced to stay in order to fulfill your holy will.' Now I think that's a very interesting
statement against my will. In other words, obedience is forcing her to write. Jesus is forcing her to
write. Hence, she says, 'against my will.' So Jesus replied, 'This is extremely important
underlying it in green, white and gold.' He said, 'My daughter, the living in my will brings with itself
the loss of any right to one's own will.' Now that's where most human beings balk. They don't mind a
holy spirituality, they don't mind beautiful writings, don't mind all kinds of things, but not
that I have to give up the rights to my own will, that I have to actually surrender. So this is about
abandonment. This is the urgent issue for all of us. So the living in my will brings with itself
the loss of any right to one's own will. All the rights belong to the divine will. In other words,
only one will can operate within us. You can't have two wills operating within you.
The kingdom divided against itself will fall. That's what Jesus said. So there has to be one will.
You know, we're inclined to agree to a certain amount and to be very generous we'll give more
and more, but all is a different subject. And if the soul does not lose her rights, Jesus said,
'It cannot be called true living in my will.' So here's a big warning for us. We can say all the
beautiful prayers in the divine will, in the divine will, and we're in the divine will for the moment
we're saying those prayers. That's fine. But living in the divine will means abandonment,
surrendering our will to the divine. He has to take over. Now, in a previous life in your
charismatic prayer groups, people used to sing, 'Rain in me, sovereign Lord, rain in me,
rain in me, sovereign Lord, rain in me.' That's precisely what he wants to do in the divine will.
And it's beautiful to sing it. As a beautiful tune, I didn't try it, aren't you? And it's wonderful
to sing it. It's quite another matter altogether to live it. It's a different subject to live it.
If the soul does not lose her rights, that is to our own will, it cannot be called true living in my
will. At the most it can be called living resigned. Jesus said, 'In fact, living in my will is not
merely that she does her own action according to my will.' That was the normal thing you had before
divine will. But that the whole interior, that's Deuteronomy 6, 4 to 10. You must love the Lord
with all your heart and all your soul and all your mind and all your being. This is total surrender.
This is abandonment, okay? But that the whole interior of the person must give place to not one
affection, not one thought, not one desire and not even one breath in which the divine will doesn't
have its place. Now for that I want to give you two Corinthians 10, 5, that every single thought
must be captured and given to Christ. Okay. And this sentence alone covers all the early volumes
in which we reminded each other that the motto had to be not my will, but thine be done.
And if we're not surrendering our will to the divine will, we can say all the prayers we like.
We can have all the beautiful liturgies. You can have all the beautiful books. You can read anything
you like. If you're not actually laying down your will to the divine will, you're not there.
It's actually that simple. And then Jesus goes on, 'Nor would my will tolerate even one human
affection of which it is not the life.' In other words, we have to really surrender to him.
The divine will would feel disgusted to let the soul live in its will with her own affections,
thoughts and other things with the human could have. But you see, I've long experienced giving
retreats to people over 40 years. And I know that people are prepared to do all kinds of things
but my thoughts are my own. Thank you. And so to surrender our thoughts to the Lord
is a terrible sacrifice. You really are abandoning yourself. So Jesus said, and do you think it's easy
that a person would willingly lose these rights? No, he said, it's very difficult. It's actually
very difficult. Rather, there are souls who when they reach the point of losing all their rights
over their own will, they draw back. Now, this is the bit I really want to emphasize tonight,
they draw back. And they content themselves with conducting a life in the middle. Now,
I'm going to talk to you about a life in the middle. In fact, losing one's rights
is the greatest sacrifice that a creature could do. He admits it. He knows it's extremely difficult
for us. But it is the one who desposes my goodness to open the doors of my will for her.
Now, notice what he's saying. Now, we go in temporarily into the divine will when we fuse
to say beautiful prayers and all the rest of it. Going in permanently is a different subject.
So, what I want to do is read for you Philippians chapter three,
Philippians chapter three from verse seven to 16. Because what the Lord is actually talking about,
he says, Saint Paul says, "But whatever profit I had in the past in my old life," he said,
"that's gone. I consider it as nothing. I consider everything as a loss compared to the surpassing
greatness of knowing Christ Jesus, my Lord. For whose sake I have lost all things I consider
them rubbish, that I may gain Christ and be found in him not having a righteousness of my own that
comes from the law, but that which comes through Christ himself, the righteousness that comes from
God and is by faith. I want to know Christ, I want to know the power of his resurrection,
and I want the fellowship of sharing in his sufferings, becoming like him in his death. So,
somehow I can attain to the resurrection of the dead." Now, here is Saint Paul saying that even at
the beginning of the church, they understood that the people who can experience the fullness of what
Christ is offering are those who surrender everything. You don't surrender everything,
you don't get it. Some people are satisfied with the lick of the lollipop, they don't want the
whole thing. So, let me read a small little bit of this and then I'm going to give you stuff about
living in the middle. In fact, he said, "Losing one's rights is the greatest sacrifice that a
creature could do, but it's the one that disposes my goodness to open the doors of my will to her."
Now, this means that we've to do a lot before the doors are opened wide for us to enter into that
extraordinary relationship that Louisa had with the Blessed Trinity. It doesn't happen overnight.
There is a great journey that you and I have to take. So, he says, "It's the laying down
of our will before the divine will that disposes him to really open the doors for us."
Therefore, not my will, but thine be done has to be our daily motto.
In fact, losing one's rights is the greatest sacrifice that a creature could do, but it is the
one which disposes my goodness to open the doors of my will for her and letting her live in it to
give her my divine rights in exchange. Why should he give us divine rights if we have not even given
him our human rights? I mean, what he's giving to us is so out of proportion to what we're giving
to him that it's not a matter for discussion. It's incredible what he's giving to us.
Therefore, he said, "Be attentive. I never go out of the boundaries of my will." Okay, so we just
want to give you a couple of examples here. If you have watched Climbers on Mount Everest,
there's three stages on the way up and the higher up you go, the more rubbish there is left from
people who have abandoned the climb at stage two and stage three has the biggest advantage of
rubbish altogether. And the amazing thing is the number of people who got to stage three and didn't
complete the small bit to finish it. Now, Saint John of the Cross says exactly the same thing
about the spiritual life. And he says that there are two stages of purification, one that everybody
goes through and then an internal purification, which he calls the second dark night of the soul.
But he says, "Oh, people balk at that one." They won't let this internal purification happen,
or they let it go a certain distance and then they say, "No." And what he says is that many
people stop about four yards from sanctity. Now, he may not have used the word yard,
he might have used some other measurement. But in other words, very close to the goal, we actually
stop. Now, close to the goal is that we're doing all this wonderful prayers and acts and rounds and
god knows whatever in the divine will, but we don't actually lay down the will. If we don't lay
down the will, we cannot receive the divine will as ours. He says it here, it's as clear as anything.
It would mean that we would be like the chosen people in the Old Testament who wanted all the
privileges that God would give to them, but they wanted it on their own terms. Most people are like
that. They'd like it on their own terms. There are people who would say, "Thus far and no further,"
they may not actually use those words, but they actually stop.
And they'll say, if they're talking to you, "Well, I need some kind of control over my own life."
They can't hand it all over. But if you don't hand it all over, you don't get all of him.
If we hand it over all, he gives us all. Okay. So let's look at this life in the middle.
You will read and you'll enjoy Louis' writings. You'll save the divine will prayers and enjoy them.
You will do the hours of the Passion, but you won't give up your own will.
And you might do it every now and then. You'll do this sometimes when it suits you,
or you may do it on some issues, but not on other issues. There are some things and you just say,
"That's my territory. Nobody's moving into that one." And so we're saying, "Thus far and no further
thing to Jesus." And if we say, "Thus far and no further," that's the end of this great exchange
of divine will. If you're the type of person who wants the freedom of your own thoughts for yourself,
and you won't make the sacrifice of two Corinthians 10, 5, that every thought is to be captured and
given to Christ, well, how can his thoughts flow in yours?
If you want the freedom of indulging all your own feelings and desires and everything else,
how can his flow in yours? If we want the freedom to have all our private reactions to people and
things, we don't want to surrender these to Christ. And we'd say, "Ah, come on. I'd have nothing left
for myself. I'd have nothing left. Do you see that we want something left?" And the answer is precisely,
Christ would take over and the divine will would reign in you and you'd not only become a saint,
you become a super saint because of the level that God would raise you to.
So we either blow our own foolish little trumpets or we blow the trumpet of heaven. One or the other.
So you will get divine will with complete surrender of the human will. Now, I know both people do that
step by step. Some day just say to him, "Lord, this is it. I'm gone." Like the child standing at the
the high jump, you know, over a swimming pool. The one who thinks about it and measures the
length and everything won't jump. And then another one comes along and say, "Okay, I'm jumping." And
they jump. They're the swimmer. They'll become the Olympic swimmers. Okay. So the Lord admits that
this is a very difficult thing for us. It's very costly for us because it's the great sacrifice and
he's not going to ask anything more once we have given him this. But this was the reason why we were
created. That we would actually give this sacrifice to him to let him return to take up his reign as
king. We have this incredible privilege of knitting the red carpet for his return. And I don't know,
I don't know about you, but I wouldn't mind being a stitch on a red carpet under his feet. I think
it'd be wonderful. Well, we have to allow God to have his divine rights upon the earth. That's
actually the issue here. So I would suggest that you go over this very slowly and go over it a
number of times. I like writing out point by point what is being said so that I can actually hear it.
Okay, so let's just make three statements for you to finish that. Living in the divine will is the
crucifixion of self will. Crucifixion means painful death. Living in the divine will is the
crucifixion of the heart. All the failings and desires and all the rest of it. And living in the
divine will is the greatest gift I can give to God. And then you have to decide whether you're going
or whether you're not going. So let's go into October the second 1924. The effects of adoration
done in the divine will. So Louisa said, I felt all embittered because of the privation of my
sweet Jesus or how much harder and more bitter my exile becomes without the one who forms my whole
life. I want to give you Sam 73 verses 25 and 26 for that. And then she said, I prayed Jesus to
have compassion on me and to not leave me at the mercy of myself. Now, if you look at that carefully,
I have colored it for myself. And I said, Lord, don't ever leave me at the mercy of myself.
I am my own worst enemy. I don't know about anybody else. We often say that that man is his
own worst enemy or that woman is their own worst enemy. Look in the mirror. I'm my own worst enemy.
Lord, don't leave me at the mercy of myself. While I was saying this, Louisa said, my beloved Jesus
made himself seen as he was squeezing my heart tightly with his hands and then binding me all
over with a little rope of light. Now that light is the divine will, little string of divine will.
But so tightly as to deprive me of the slightest motion. Then afterwards, he laid himself within me
and we suffered together because they are one, John 14 verses 20 to 21, you in me and I in you.
In the meantime, I felt myself being transported outside of myself towards the vault of heaven.
I seemed to encounter the celestial father and the Holy Spirit. Jesus, who was with me,
placed himself between the father and the Holy Spirit. Why? Because he is our mediator.
Okay. And he put me on the lap of the father. Why? Because he is the savior.
And the father seemed to have been waiting for me with so much love because God is love,
one, John four, seven, that he pressed me to his bosom and identifying me with his will. Imagine God,
the father identifying you with his will. You're definitely in the divine will. He communicated his
power to me. Now don't forget, she said, and so did the other two divine persons. So don't forget
volume one, Louisa had a marriage among the three divine persons. That's back in volume one.
So she has this extraordinary relationship with God. But while they communicated themselves to me
one by one, they all became one because our God is three in one. And I felt I was being infused.
Watch this now. This is this wonderful description. I felt I was being infused with
altogether the will of the power of the father, the will of the wisdom of the son and the will of
the love of the Holy Spirit. But who can say what I felt was being infused into my soul? She said,
she couldn't have words for that. And beloved Jesus said to her, daughter of our eternal will,
prostrate yourself before our supreme majesty. The more we get to know God, the more we will adore.
The less we know him, the less we adore.
Because after all, if our planet is a speck of a speck of a speck in the universe,
what am I? That's Sam 8 and verse 5 or 6 it is, Lord, what is man that you would care for him or
even the son of man that you would notice him? So daughter of our will prostrate yourself before
the supreme majesty and offer your adoration, homage and your praise in the name of all souls.
Now all souls means from Adam to Zachary, so I usually say from age z. And do it with the power
of our will. Do it with the wisdom and with the will of our supreme love. So here we are praying
with God. We're praying with the power and the wisdom and the love of God. You can't pray with
the higher power than that. We will feel in you the power of our will adoring us,
the wisdom of our will glorifying us and the love of our will loving us and praising us.
And since the power wisdom and love of the three divine persons are in communication
with the intellect, memory and will of all human beings, we will feel your adoration, homage and
praise flow within all the intelligences of creatures. So here we are, we come with the power,
wisdom and love of the three divine persons to place our adoration, homage, praise and glory
and all the rest of it before the divine majesty. And because the power, wisdom and love of God
are in communication with the three powers of the soul, then you are in connection
with every intelligence of a human being. This is how you influence the human race from within.
And this adoration, praise and honor will rise between heaven and earth and make us hear
the echo of our own power, wisdom and love adoring us, praising us and loving us.
Greater adoration, a more noble homage, love and praise more divine you could not actually
give us. It's not possible. No other act can equal these acts. Now the thing that's extremely
important about this is that it's not Louisa speaking, it's God himself speaking and God is truth.
No other act can equal these acts. No other act can give us as much glory and as much love
because we see hovering within the act of the creature, the power, the wisdom and the reciprocal
love of the three divine persons. This is Trinitarian prayer. And you can see that a person living
in the divine will has a Trinitarian spirituality. And if you have a Trinitarian spirituality,
it means it is universal. It's not limited to any particular group. It's always love without borders.
Always love without borders. God's love is love without borders.
And so Jesus said, how could we not enjoy these acts and give them supremacy over all others?
So Louisa said, I prostrated myself before the supreme majesty adoring it,
praising it and loving it in the name of all, praying with the power, the wisdom and the love
of their will, which I felt within me. But who can say the effects of this? I've no words to express
it and therefore I move on. So here you've been told very, very clearly that acts in the divine
will bring in the power of God, the father, the wisdom of God, the son and the love of God,
the Holy Spirit. And we're taking the gracious power in heaven. And we're using that to influence
all human beings on earth. You can't get anything bigger than that.
So afterwards, Louisa said, I received communion and I was fusing myself in the will of my highest
good Jesus in order to find the whole of creation in it. Now in the last paragraph,
we found all human beings that we could actually touch the intellects of all human beings in this
prayer. Now he says, you can touch all of creation in this prayer as well. So she said, I was fusing
myself in the will of my highest good Jesus in order to find the whole of creation in it.
So that no one might be absent from the roll call. And together with me, all might prostrate
themselves at the feet of Jesus in the most holy Eucharist, to adore him, to love him and to bless
him. Now notice the priority that has been given to her in this prayer. And that is that the whole
human race must one day bend the knee and worship Christ. And he is present to us body, blood, soul,
and divinity in the Eucharist. Okay. So I want to give you Philippians chapter two
and verses six to 11. So that's Philippians two, six to 11. Because having his state was divine,
he did not cling to his divine state. He became like us and becoming like us. He was humbler still,
even to accepting death on a cross. So that's the lowest point. And then God raised him high,
gave him the name that is above all other names. And that the name above all other names, of course,
is the divine name. It's Yahweh, the name above all names. In other words, he is declared God in
the resurrection. And as a result, all creatures in the heavens, on the earth and in the underworld,
must bend the knee and acknowledge Jesus Christ as Lord. And that is what has to happen on this earth.
At the moment, things are pretty awful. I mean, we have our churches are mostly,
mostly, I'm not talking about COVID-19 now, but our churches are mostly empty. They're open all day,
and who goes in for adoration and praise. So the Lord wants this. And Louisa said,
while I was doing this, I felt somehow distracted and trying to find all creation things in his
divine will, so that the love and praise and adoration Jesus from everybody would be one.
And Jesus in seeing me as though hampered gathered the whole of creation onto his lap.
Isn't that the simplest possible image of Jesus as God? He can gather the entire
universe onto his lap. You see that Sam 8 verse 3, you made everything with the tips of your fingers,
the Samus says. It's just the work of your tips of your fingers. It's nothing to you.
And of course, if you've read these volumes, when Jesus tells us over and over again,
that it only took one fiat of his to bring the entire creation into being.
Of course, you're talking about supreme power. But I just love this image that
that the whole of creation was brought onto his lap. Because you heard earlier that they took
Louisa onto their lap. Now they're taking the whole of creation as well. And he said,
"My daughter, I placed all creation on my lap, that it may be easier for you to find
and to call everyone together with you, so that not one thing which came from me
may not give me through you the return of love and adoration which refits me as all things belong
to me." So in these acts and prayers in the divine will, the Lord wants us to bring all creation back
to him and all human beings back to him, so that he does. "My daughter, I placed all of creation on
my lap, that it may be easier for you to find and to call everyone together with you, so that not
one thing which came from me may not give me through you the return of love and adoration which
refits me as things that belong to me." So it's through our prayers in the divine will that all the
voids that have been left there by other human beings have got to be all filled in of the adoration
praise and glory that is due to God. And Jesus said, "I wouldn't be fully content
if any of them were missing." And so I want to give you Romans 819 that it is through the true
sons of God that all of creation is going to be healed and brought into its final order.
"In my will," Jesus said, "I want to find everything in you. This is universal love. It includes
all creation and all creatures." That's why we do the rounds of creation and redemption
and sanctification. After this, Louisa said, "It became easier for me to find and call
all of creation together with me, so that we all might praise and love our highest good Jesus,
but all marvel. Each created thing, she said, contained a distinct reflection and a special love
of Jesus. And Jesus received the return of these reflections
and a return of his love. So what I want to do is read for you, I want to give you Colossians
chapter 1 from verse 16. And here again you have Paul really able to put this into words.
It started Colossians 1.15, "He that is Jesus is the image of the invisible God. He is the first
born of all creation. For by him all things were created, things in heaven and things on earth,
visible and invisible. Whether they are thrones or powers or rulers or authorities,
all things were created by him and for him. He is before all things and in him all things
hold together. He is the head of the body at the church. He is the beginning and is the first born
from the dead, so that in everything he might have the supremacy. And God was pleased to have all
his fullness dwell in him, the fullness of the Godhead bodily dwells in him. So Jesus has made
it possible for a Louisa to be able to connect with all of creation everything that has come into
being and with all human beings in order to fill the voids of the honor and praise and glory and
adoration that is due to God. Can you imagine how grateful the people who have gone on to the other
side whether they're in purgatory or heaven and they find people on earth filling in the voids further?
Can you imagine how grateful they will be that all of this is done because once they get to the
other side they will see all that they should have done and now they see little people like us
trying to fill in these voids. It will no wonder Jesus says over and over, they begin to feast,
they begin to celebrate. So let's come to October the 6th, 1924.
How the divine will is the primary heartbeat of the soul and of all creation things. Now again
we're going to be talking about abandonment to the divine will is the big issue.
So Louisa said I was fusing all of myself in the holy divine will. Notice the all of myself.
I think it's important for us to say to the Lord I fuse all of me in all of you.
This is your handing over. This is your surrendering of yourself and he says that each time we do it
another little layer of divine will is added to us like a painter adding another stroke of color
to a painting. Jesus she said moving in my interior which means the kingdom of God is
actually there. That's Luke 17 21 and 1 Corinthians 3 16. He said my daughter how beautiful it is to
see his soul fuse herself in my will. As she fuses herself in it the created heartbeat takes its place
and its life in the uncreated heartbeat and forms one single thing with it and it runs and beats
together with the uncreated heartbeat. This is the greatest happiness for the human heart
to palpitate in the eternal heartbeat of its creator. My will puts it in flight and the human
heartbeat flings itself into the center of its creator. Now this is just the simple act of fusing
which is absolutely incredible. So as a result of this he's going to talk about two heart beats.
Then Louisa said to him tell me my love how many times does your volition go around
within creatures. That's an extraordinary question to ask since he's doing it all the time.
And Jesus said my daughter in each heartbeat of the creature my will forms its complete
round in all of creation. This is nearly impossible to take on board. In each heartbeat of the creature
my will forms its complete round in all creation. And just as the heartbeat in the creature is
continuous and if the heartbeat ceases then life ceases in the same way my will more than a heartbeat
in order to give divine life to souls goes round and forms the heartbeat of my will in each heart.
Now we have fused so there's two heart beats. One is ours trying to fuse in him and his taking
over. It's absolutely beautiful. Let me just read that again. He said my daughter in each heartbeat
of the creature my will forms its complete round in all of creation. Now you know that the divine
will is a singularity, a single point. Everything is there, there's no past or future. Everything
is present and just as the heartbeat in the creature is continuous and without its life would cease.
He said my will which is more than a heartbeat in order to give divine life to souls goes round
and forms the heartbeat of my will in her. So there's our heartbeat and the heartbeat of the divine will.
See then he said how my will is present in each person. Now he doesn't say in those who believe
in each person as the primary heartbeat because hers is secondary. Why is he the primary heartbeat?
God is the the the prime mover as the church has always taught us. He is the one who enables us
to live. If he takes his divine will away from us we simply disintegrate. There wouldn't even be
anything left. So he's the primary heartbeat and ours is secondary. Even more if she feels her heartbeat
is by virtue of the heartbeat of my will. Even more this will of mine forms in her two heartbeats,
one for the human heart as life of the body and one for the soul the heartbeat of the soul.
But you want to know what the heartbeat of my will does in the creature. If she thinks my will
runs and calculates like blood in the veins of the soul and gives her the divine thought
that she may put aside the human thought so we're talking about people in the divine will here.
We start off by we fused at the beginning and then he said he formed two heartbeats in us.
So now we come to the practicality. If the person wants to think my will runs and
circulates like blood in the veins of the soul and gives her the divine thought
that she may put aside the human thought and give place to the thought of my will.
Now that's one thing on paper it's quite another matter all together to do it and if I'm to do it
I have to be conscious of setting aside my thought and inviting his thought through.
If I want him to speak through me because he's going to talk about that in a moment I've got to
consciously set aside my words and ask him to flow through my words. We ask him his thought
to flow through ours, his gazes to flow through ours, his words to flow through ours, his actions
to flow through ours so that ours are Christ dead. So this is what he's saying here.
If she speaks the word of my will wants its place. If she works, if she walks, if she loves,
my will wants to place the place of her work of her step and of her love.
The love and the jealousy of my will in the creature are so great that while it palpitates,
if the creature wants to think it makes itself thought. Now the jealousy of God is extremely
important. I'll just give you Exodus 20 verse 5, Deuteronomy 5-9 and Zechariah 1-14. I could give
you lots more just to give you a taste. If you have given birth to a child and you've brought
a child into the world, you have an extraordinary jealousy for that child. You're the one who wants
to take care of the child. You're the one who wants to teach it everything. You're the one that
wants to enable this child to develop. You're the one who wants to give it all its experience.
You're the one who wants to do this and this and this and this. That's the jealousy. It's this
wonderful protectiveness that God has. And if we're willing to live in the divine will,
God has an extraordinary protectiveness about us and that he doesn't want other influences
to come in and spoil everything because he is doing a divine work. And I think that
when God is working in the soul, you should put up a big notice, danger, God at work.
Keep all other workers out. That's his jealousy. That he wants to make sure that the work that
actually is done in us is truly divine. That there aren't mixtures of human in it because that would
spoil it for him. So the love and the jealousy of my will in the creature is so great that while
it palpitates, if the creature wants to think the divine will makes itself thought, if she wants
to look, the divine will makes itself I. If she wants to speak, the divine will makes itself word.
Now, let's look at that just for a minute. If we want to speak, the divine will wants
to be the word, but I have to push aside to let that word come through.
If the divine will wants to be my gaze, I have to let the gaze of the divine will come through.
So I can't be gazing at something that is sinful or something that's wrong or something that's
self-indulgent because that's not his gaze. If I want to work or walk or anything else,
I'd be conscious that I'm setting myself aside in order to let him come through. And this consciousness
needs to grow. I mean, you know that I've been teaching for the last 45 years and I learned very
early on to say to the Lord, if they could hear you, they wouldn't want me. They wouldn't look at me
for two seconds if you were going to be around. So let me consciously put myself aside and let you
come through. That's what they're talking about here. And it is a conscious decision on our part.
If you do it frequently enough, it'll become natural and normal for you.
And I would suggest that if you find yourself in a situation where you're not really sure
how to respond to something, to say to the Lord, give me the words, give me the thoughts,
and then you're reminding yourself to push aside and let him come through.
If the person wants to work, the divine will makes itself work. And if she wants to walk,
it makes itself foot. In other words, he becomes all things for us. It's absolutely amazing.
If she wants to love, the divine will makes itself fire. Now notice the image he gives you for love.
If you look at society out there that is calling all kinds of sexual aberrations
love, then you realize that what the Lord is speaking about is a completely different reality
altogether. And when he uses the term fire, there's so much in the Bible about this that I would really
talk about nothing else for the rest of the time. So I'm just going to give you a few references.
Matthew chapter three, verses 11 and 12, that Jesus was to baptize us with the Holy Spirit and fire.
And Hebrews 12, 29, our God is a consuming fire. Now you'll find that also in Exodus,
because when God came to the people on Mount Sinai or Horeb, whichever name you use,
he came to them as fire. And it was consuming the mountain and they were terrified.
But the strange thing is that when Moses went up into the mountain and up into the presence of God,
Moses wasn't consumed. And when Moses saw God as fire in the burning bush, the thing that
attracted his attention was that the bush wasn't burned up. When you study the volumes of Louisa,
you realize, particularly now as we're moving on a little bit, that the divine fire inside of Louisa
literally consumes her life, because she has to become completely spiritualized.
We have to turn into light. We have to be transformed completely. And so initially,
all the drafts of our lives has got to be all burned up. And then gradually,
we have to move from just human thought and human action to divine thought and divine action.
And as he purifies us more and more and more and more and more, we become light. That's why I loved
that little rope that he had around her at two messages back that it was a rope of light.
If we want to love with the divine will, the divine will will turn into fire.
In some, Jesus said, the divine will runs and goes around within each act of the person.
In order to take its primary place, which is due to it, and that's what we do by surrendering
the human will is that we give the primary place to the divine will so that our acts become divine
and not just human. But to our greatest sorrow, Jesus said, the creature denies
it this place of honor. So that's when the creature denies the divine will, the place of honor,
we're insisting on doing our own thing. And the creature gives the place to its own human will,
and according to this spirituality that the Lord is leading us through, that's a complete disaster.
And my will, he said, is forced to remain in the creature as if it had no thought,
no eye, no word, no hands, no feet. In other words, we make God impotent in us. It's incredible.
But it's our decision. And it's our continuous decisions that do that. We're not allowing him to
work. If you switch off all the lights in your house in the middle of winter, the fact that you've
no light doesn't mean there's no electricity. It means you switched it all off. And if you switch
on all the lights and all the rooms, you get the light. If when we surrender to the divine will in
all our thoughts and our actions and our words, yes, the divine will takes over. So this surrender,
this abandonment is the thing that we've got to be thinking about all the time.
So he says it's a terrible sorrow when we are so foolish as to let ourselves feel that God is far
away and that God is not working in us. And he says it's entirely your own fault. It's your own
decisions. So this reminds me of something you've heard me say before. And that is that I often
describe Catholics as people who sit outside of a bank starving to death, but the practice they own
the bank is totally foolish. And if we know all of this about the divine will and just what the
Lord can do in us and through us, and we don't let it happen, you need a new definition of foolishness.
It's amazing. Next paragraph, Jesus says, "Ah, but do you want to know who gives me the field
to let the divine will operate as the heartbeat and life of the soul?" Now when he says gives me
the field, he says, "Give me the space to work." He says, "It's the one who lives in the divine will
that allows God the space to really work. Oh how well does my will carry out its life and constitutes
itself the thought of her thought, the eye of her eye, the word of her mouth, heartbeat of her heart
and so on with all the rest." This means that when we get to the stage where we really are living
abandoned to the divine will at every moment, other people will see the Lord in you, hear him
through you, experience him coming from you because it's his thought, his gaze, his words, his actions.
And he said, "I become the heartbeat of her heart and so on. Oh how quickly we begin to understand
each other." That means you really come to know God. And my will obtains the intent of forming its
life in the soul of the creature. And it's not only in the creature with reason, that means it's not
only in human beings that he's able to form his life. We are the ones making this decision.
It's not only in the creature with reason that my will holds its primary place and is like a heartbeat
which giving the circulation to the life of the soul runs to give life to all the acts of the creature.
But it happens in all created things. Now we're the only ones with free will
but all the others benefit. That's your Romans 8, 19 again. My will holds its primary place
and circulates as the heartbeat of life from the tiniest created thing up to the greatest one.
And none of them can move from the power and dimension of my will because they don't have free
will. We're the only creatures in all of the universe who have free will. And therefore
we are very responsible for the actions that we do. My will, he said, makes itself the life of the
Asia sky and maintains its celestial color with ever new, ever new and vivid nor can it fade or
change or turn pale because my will wanted it to be so. Now we know from all that we have read
in the divine will and heard in talks on the divine will that God only has to say I want it
and it comes into being. If you have read the writings of Maria Valtorta and you read the
miracles of Jesus, she is the only person who brings out very clearly that when Jesus decides
to work a miracle, he simply says I want it. He's saying fiat. Sometimes he says this one also
but he's saying I want it. And the whole universe came into being simply because God wanted and
he says that none of the celestial bodies in the universe can change in any way from the way they
were created because God did not want them to have free will. Be too bad if the sun had free will
and decided not to shine. He said my will wanted it this way and once it is established my will
does not change. There you have the immutability of God. And this is something that our modern
generations are reviling and rebelling against and that is because they have changed their behavior
they want God's laws to change but that won't happen. God is immutable. God said something thousands
of years ago. He says it forever. Once it said that's it. God doesn't change. My will is the life of
the light and the heat of the sun. In other words it is the divine will that operates the sun.
And with its heartbeat of life it preserves its light and its heat ever equal and alive.
Keeping it immobile we would say stable in its operations without being able to move or to increase
or decrease in the good that it must do to the earth. In other words the sun is not given the freedom
to serve or not serve the earth. My will is the life of the sea he says and forms the murmuring
of its waters. My will is the darting of the fish and of the roaring waves. Oh how my will makes a
display of the power it contains and carries out its life with such great majesty and absolute
dominion in creative things that neither can the sea do without murmuring nor the fish without darting.
A simple way of saying that is he is Lord. He is God. Even more I could say that it is my will
that murmurs in the sea. It is my will that darts in the fish. Now if you continue that
meditation you'll be quite surprised. It's my will he said that forms the waves.
So let's look at this. Divine will murmurs in the sea. The divine will howls in the storm.
The divine will shakes the earth in its wrath. The divine will punishes us in a tsunami.
The divine will whispers in the gentle breeze. The divine will smiles at us in the beauty of the
flowers. And now we're going to go on with this. My will murmurs in the sea. It is my will that darts
in the fish. It is my will that forms the waves. And with its roaring makes itself heard. Now that's
Amos chapter 1 verse 2 and Amos chapter 3 verses 7 to 8. And what Amos says is the lion roars who
cannot help feeling afraid. Now the lion is the image of the king. So when the lion roars in the
forest all the other little animals scurry for shelter. And when the sea roars you have to take note.
My will forms the waves and with its roaring makes itself heard that its life is there
which can do everything as it best pleases. My will is the heartbeat of life in the bird that
warbles in the chirping, chipping of the chick in the lamb that bleeds in the turtle dove that
moans in the plants that vegetate in the air that everyone breeds. We've been given around.
Isn't it lovely? In some in everything my will has its life. And it forms with its power the act
that it wants. This is Sam 139 verses 7 to 12. It maintains harmony in all creation things
and forms in them the different effects, colors, offices with which each of them contains. But you
know why? It is to make myself known to creatures, to go to her to court her to love her with as many
different acts of my will for as many different things as I created. So here the lord is saying
that he is speaking to all people all the time in all of creation all around us. That if you never
pick up the holy book to read it that he is speaking to you in all of creation. Nobody can say they
haven't heard him. My love was not content with placing my will as the heartbeat of life in the
depth of her soul but it wanted to place my will in all created things so that also from the outside
my will might never leave her. So we have the divine will outside of us in all of creation and
also operating within us the depths of our being because we cannot function without the divine will
enabling that. So that also from the outside my will might never leave her and she might be preserved
and grow in the sanctity of my very will. And all created things might be incitement,
example, voice and continuous call for her. So here the lord gives us another way of looking
at the weather, the call of God. And if we're having climate change don't you think God is
calling us in a new way? If we're having storms isn't God lifting up his voice as the Psalms would
say? So everything would be a continuous call for her. So this is the divine lover reaching out to
all of his children regardless of whether they have a good faith or a bad faith or no faith.
To make her always run in the fulfillment of my will the only purpose for which she was created.
Now we're reading this over and over and over again in these messages that the only reason why we were
created was to do the divine will. Okay, but the creature makes herself deaf to the many voices
in creation. She makes herself blind to the sight of so many examples. And if she opens her eyes she
fixes them on her own will. So for all of that I want to give you Sam 38 verse 13 and I want to
give you Isaiah chapter six verses nine to ten. Isaiah said they will see and see and never see
they'll hear and hear and they'll never get it and they've blinded their eyes they've deafened
their ears they've hardened their hearts with sin so that they they need to be converted and live.
So Jesus said what a sorrow this is therefore I recommend to you he said never want to go out of
my will we would say never choose because wanting is choosing never choose to go out of my will
if you do not want to multiply my sorrow and let the purpose for which you were created be lost.
So we're close to eight thirty so I'm going to stop there tonight.